Yvonne Catterfeld ist wieder da die
Schauspielerin und Sängerin stellt ihr
neues Album Blau im Blau vor
ein sehr persönliches Album ihr Freund
der Schauspieler Oliver Wnuk hat einige
Texte beigesteuert in der
online-talkshow Clixoom erklärt sie die
Auswirkungen
aber natürlich ist da sehr viel
persönliches dabei helfen
es wird immer nur ein Teil Preise von
mir beispielsweise an die
öffentlichkeit kommen wenn ich den
anderen einfach Prozent geschätzt in
einem Raum lasse
trotzdem ist es so dass ich meine
Meinung sage ich möchte dass gewisse
Facetten Durchkommen
auch bei Pixum gibt die ein Geheimnis
Preis ich bin so extrem
Lampenfieber ich Angst
ein vermisstes auch nicht gerade positiv
also bei mir ist es eher
so ein bisschen ist gut aber wenn er es
sich leisten ich glaube ich Krieg ich
hatte sehr niedrigen Blutdruck und ich
glaube ich die Banken sehr sehr hohen
Blutdruck
das heißt ich kann Manuel Wassum ein
Hertz wichtig bei Verhören und das ist
nicht gut ganz ohne Herz erobern Blau im
Blau und das neue Album
ein Vorgeschmack auf der Webseite von
Yvonne Catterfeld das ganze Werk ab
sofort im Handel